really great world cup one of the best
ever from what everybody tells me one of
the best ever and also doing so well
[Music]
I watched quite a bit in the United
States they call in soccer and I watch
quite a bit of it and I watched the
entire follow and the 70 finals and they
were really spectacular games but it was
beautifully done so congratulations on
their most importantly we have a lot of
good things to talk about and things to
talk about we have discussions on
everything from trade to military to
missiles the nuclear to chop traffic
we'll be talking a little bit about
China a mutual friend
President Xi
[Music]
I think we have great opportunities
together as two countries that frankly
we have not been getting along very well
for the last number of years I've been
here not too long that it's getting
close to two years but I think we will
end up having an extraordinary
relationship I hope so I've been sitting
and I'm sure you've heard over the years
and as I campaign that getting along
with Russia is a good thing not a bad
thing and I think the world wants to see
us get along we are the two great
nuclear powers we have 90 percent of the
nuclear and that's not a good thing it's
a bad thing and I think we hopefully can
do something about that because it's not
a positive force it's a negative force
so we'll be talking about that among
other things
[Music]
[Music]
and with that the world awaits and I
look forward to our personal discussion
which I think begins now and then we're
going to meet our whole team you have
quite a few representatives on I do and
we all have a lot of questions and
hopefully we'll come up with answers
most importantly it's great to be with
you
[Music]
thank you very much thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you everybody